you know at first i was going to call
this next story
mark zuckerberg visibly befuddled
by aoc's simple questions
but that would not be speaking of titles
and click bait that would not really be
an honest title for this story
these are actually pretty damn difficult
questions that aoc
asked facebook founder and ceo mark
zuckerberg
because they get to the intersection of
things like free speech
the right of a corporation to police
content voter suppression
foreign interference in elections these
actually are complicated things
what was notable was that mark
zuckerberg seemed not to have
answers as to what facebook policies are
and that's really the problematic part
so let me set it up for you we're going
to look at some
very interesting video here facebook
founder mark zuckerberg
was visibly befuddled by questions from
alexandria ocasio-cortez
because neither mark zuckerberg nor
facebook as a whole nor twitter
really have answers that feel to the
average
person satisfactory to the questions
that were being asked so let's get right
to it
congresswoman congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
questioned facebook founder mark
zuckerberg about
what will facebook take down when it
comes to news and advertisements
what kinds of ads are considered over
the line
and against the policies of facebook
with regard to
ad policy and it turns out that the
answers are both not so clear and also
it doesn't seem like it's completely
known
to mark zuckerberg which is a problem
we'll take uh will facebook take down an
ad
that says something false about a
candidate
zuckerberg says well we don't fact check
ads
well what if the ad falsely promotes the
wrong election date as an example
and targets zip codes with
disproportionately black voters
mark zuckerberg says well yeah we might
take that down then because it's not
just
fact checking it's relating to voter
suppression
but lots of things relate to voter
suppression even if they're not
about election day so where is the line
aoc says what if i
targeted uh uh candidates uh
with incorrect claims that they
supported the green new deal republican
voters might be
upset with their incumbent republican
elected officials if they believed that
those officials supported the green new
deal what if i ran an ad falsely saying
they support the green new deal
these are actually interesting questions
and i want to get into the first clip
and you will see how visibly confused
mark zuckerberg is could i pay to target
predominantly black
zip codes and advertise them the
incorrect election date
no congresswoman you couldn't we we have
even for these policies around
the newsworthiness of content that
politicians say in the general principle
that i believe that
but you said you're not going to fact
check my ass
if uh if anyone including a politician
is saying things
that can cause that is calling for
violence
or could risk imminent physical harm or
voter or census suppression when we roll
out the census suppression
policy we will take that contents out so
so you will there is some threshold
where you will fact
check political advertisements is that
what you're telling me well
congresswoman yes for specific things
like that where there's imminent risk of
harm could i
run ads targeting republicans in
primaries saying that they voted for the
green new deal
sorry can you repeat that would i be
able to run
advertisements on facebook targeting
republicans in primary saying that they
voted for the green new deal
i mean if you're not fact checking
political advertisements i'm just trying
to understand the bounds here
what's fair i uh i don't know the answer
to that off the top of my head
i think so you don't know if i'll be
able to do that
um do you see a potential problem here
with a complete lack of fact checking on
political advertisements
well congresswoman i think lying is bad
and i think if you were to run an ad
that had alive that would be
bad that's different from it being
from it from for in our position
the right thing to do to prevent uh your
constituents or people in an election
from seeing that you have lied
so we can so you won't take down lies or
you will take down lies i think it's
just a pretty
simple yes or no congresswoman uh
i'm not talking about spin i'm talking
about actual yes
in a democracy i believe that people
should be able to see for themselves
what politicians that they may or may
not vote for or you won't take them
a character for themselves so you won't
you may flag that it's wrong but you
won't take it down
congresswoman it's uh it depends on the
context that it shows up
or organic posts calling for violence
risks physical harm
could suppress votes so it is sort of a
form of fact checking that they do and
now this
really exposes that mark zuckerberg
doesn't really understand the policy
and maybe even more insidiously it's
possible that
facebook doesn't really know how they
implement the policy that they've
written down
in order to have something that they can
point to let's look at another clip aoc
here asking mark zuckerberg
how does facebook determine who is a
trusted news source because this is
something facebook it's a new initiative
at facebook
we want to mark what is likely to be an
untrustworthy source or a trustworthy
source
this is really important stuff for
independent media like our show
here is how zuckerberg handles this
question question in your ongoing dinner
parties with far-right figures some of
who advance the conspiracy theory that
white supremacy is a hoax
did you discuss so-called social media
bias against conservatives and do you
believe there is a bias
uh congresswoman um
so i don't remember everything that was
in the senate in the question i'll move
on can you explain why you've named the
daily caller a publication
white uh well-documented with ties to
white supremacists as an official fact
checker for facebook
congresswoman sure we actually don't
appoint the independent fact-checkers
they go through
an independent organization called the
independent fact-checking network that
has
a rigorous standard for who they allow
to
serve as a fact-checker so
you would say that white supremacists
tied
publications meet a rigorous standard
for fact checking
thank you congresswoman i would say that
we're not the one assessing
that that standard so on that one zuck
is just shirking responsibility he's
saying hey listen
we appointed someone else to tell us
who's trustworthy and aoc wants to get
to
well what about this particular news
outlet
that is in bed with associated with
white supremacy how did you determine
that they're trustworthy and zuckerberg
is saying we didn't determine anything
we just
outsource that to somebody else so so
far zuckerberg
is unsure about what is and isn't
allowed in facebook ads
he says that they aren't even the ones
determining
who is trustworthy none of this is
particularly inspiring of confidence
but this is actually really good stuff
to be talking about
because it's so important and the social
media platforms
are not figuring it out the most
important thing to take from this
is sure you know i mean listen
zuckerberg as a billionaire tech ceo
who doesn't have our best interests as
his priority
we know about him we know about jeff
bezos so we know about all
of that stuff that's not news we know
that we we cannot just assume
that these big tech companies and their
ceos have
the broader best interests as their top
priority that's not new
the issue here is if we had a more
educated population
a lot of these issues would not be
issues
that's not where we are right now so we
do need to figure out what the framework
is going to be
for managing these types of problems now
facebook as
mark zuckerberg makes very clear what
they want as a policy
is we will do some stuff and create
some documents to be able to point to to
make it look like we're working on this
but it's not really going to fix
anything and when we're asked about it
we'll just waffle back and forth sort of
trying to look uh
you know looking like he needs to be
rebooted control alt delete that's not
good it's not good for anyone it's not
good for users it's not good for
political discourse it's not good for
public education so really nice job
by alexandria ocasio-port cortez of
uh um pulling out from mark zuckerberg
both the ambiguities and the lack of
clarity around some of these policies
that being said this is a way bigger
issue even if mark zuckerberg had
clean-cut answers it still doesn't solve
the problem of what should be done
and how this should be managed so
excellent job
but shows us that there's a lot of work
to do along these lines
make sure you give us a like on facebook
at facebook.com
davidpakmanshow and follow the david
pakman show instagram page
at david pakman show big things are
happening there